dua lipa's known for levitating
but everything that goes up must come
down
yeah that's dua taking alipa during her
future nostalgia tour stop in milan
rocking a pink jumpsuit performing her
single be the one to be out there and
doing it feels really good no she wasn't
hallucinating
at one point dua loses her footing and
well this happened
but nothing can knock this diva down she
brushed it off by popping up and going
right back into her moves
i really have like a full choreography
routine that happens through the future
nostalgia store that i didn't have
before um so in that sense it's it's a
full-on like i like to just describe it
as like the traveling circus just go and
put on the show every night after night
and it's just
it's just a lot of fun and the part that
makes it really exciting is the reaction
from the fans and what better way to
bounce back than with a new banger on
friday duo dropped a new single and
music video for potion a collab with
calvin harris and young thug
conversations
the singer shared this behind the scenes
shot while filming the video and calvin
he celebrated the release by giving fans
a glimpse of how the song came to be a
little fender strap over the top of that
and here comes the bass
oh
beautiful smooth
and uh round
if you sprinkle the guitar
then uh facetime doer forget to record
the sound i'll make you up for it she
goes definitely
and then that's the tune that's how you
do it you can do it too
so hats off to dua a girl who makes her
own rules
[Music]
and never stops dancing
[Music]
you